hello Upsy little doll tears aren't a
woman's only weapon the best ones
between your legs man how to use it
drink hey youtubers it's Charlie welcome
to my game of Thrones Season 4 preview
for Cersei Lannister I know I know I've
been putting it off all week but I had
so many new TV shows to get out this
week I didn't want to rush it but
seriously will not be denied and what
best to follow up in American Horror
Story video then with the
next best game of thrones character
seriously Lannister technically
seriously doesn't have any witchcraft
powers unless you consider that time
during the Battle of Blackwater Bay when
she told Sansa that she could use her
sex to mind control men yep she's
actually one of the most complex
characters on a game of thrones which is
why I like her so much it's just an
awesome but she's one of the only
characters on the show that has not hit
rock bottom yet that moment where a
character looks inward and they
basically have to turn their life around
in order to survive that's right most of
the other characters like Jon Snow
Tyrion Jamie Sansa have all had moments
like that even Samwell had to face the
white Walker seriously really hasn't had
that white Walker moment yet but it's
coming in season 4 so in case you
haven't seen my other Game of Thrones
Season 4 preview videos beware for
spoilers for everything from seasons 123
and partial spoilers for books 4 and 5
i'll briefly mention Joffrey because you
can't really talk about Cersei without
talking about Joffrey just because it's
kind of an extension of that character
in King's Landing I'll be doing a
separate video for King crossbow so
don't worry though well in season for
Joffrey's gonna continue to get crazier
and crazier and seriously mostly gets a
lot of the blame for that just because
she's supposed to be watching him
technically she's Queen regent even
though Tywin has come back and kind of
taken over the power in King's Landing
but after certain super spoilery events
seriously won't have to worry about that
anymore we'll talk about what she does
after that in a second but one of the
really cool things about season four is
is that it will be much more Cersei
heavy the really cool thing about book
for feast for crows is that it actually
features Cersei POV chapters which means
we get to find out what's going on in
her crazy crazy head which is just
amazing he basically begins this descent
into madness that's really reminiscent
for all of you avatar last airbender
fans when Azula went crazy in season
three Cersei is kind of like the Azula
of Game of Thrones in season four well
maybe slide
less crazy sir she does not breathe blue
fire if you remember all the way back in
season one seriously made this big deal
about playing a game of thrones playing
to win basically you win or you die well
basically she's done a lot of things
along the way to try and win that game
that are going to come back and bite her
in the ass and season four so to speak
specifically to what's going to be going
on with Cersei in season four remember I
said certain huge events are going to
happen that are gonna kind of pave the
way for her to become queen region again
which means she's going to start taking
back some of the power that she really
really wanted she basically replaces
most of the small council with her own
advisors meaning that she gets to
control almost everything just because
they'll do whatever she says but
eventually the rug will get pulled out
from under her and it won't be in the
way you typically expect one of my
previous Game of Thrones videos i talked
about how little finger used to be the
master of coin in King's Landing and he
basically just borrowed money for the
crown for the Baratheon and they're
basically in super debt right now so
that'll end up coming back to bite
seriously in the ass even though she
really didn't have a lot to do with it
it'll end up becoming a huge problem for
her but that will kind of lead to a
couple other things that I'll talk about
in a future video either way she's going
to end up and change by the end of the
season I'm calling it now it just seems
like the logical place to leave her
character before season 5 basically
going from the most powerful person in
King's Landing to literally ending up
not in the black cells but definitely in
jail but let me know what you think is
going to happen to seriously in season
four is she going to end up and chains
by the end of the season and what are
Jamie and the rest of her minions going
to do about it there's this really
awesome mental list that Jamie keeps
telling himself in his own head that I
want you all to remember just say it out
loud and let me know what you think it
means lancel osmond kettle black and
moon boy since so many of you requested
it my next game of thrones season 4
preview will be for Gendry be sure to
subscribe to get that video i'll try and
post it on Monday morning remember
tonight is legend of korra and then on
sunday the first episode of walking dead
so get excited i'll be posting videos
for those right after the episodes there
make sure to follow me on social for
updates but right now you can click here
to watch my american horror story coven
video it's totally awesome is
here it's like hogwarts school of
witchcraft and you can click here to get
all my other game of thrones season for
previews thank you so much for watching
high five see you guys tonight for
Legend of Korra
you